welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka invincipal in
this video we're breaking down
everything you need to know about
omniman
the superman inspired man of steel your
planet
is making a big impact on amazon's new
show invincible
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down everything you need to
know about his origins and powers
there will be full spoilers from the
comics here and if you haven't had a
chance to check them out yet then i
highly recommend that you check yourself
and check out
now if you stick around and enjoy the
video then please click the thumbs up
button
and make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into omniman
okay so when we're first introduced to
omniman well led to believe that he's a
protector of peace and justice
though he looks like henry cavill before
the effects were added to him in justice
league
the pair are actually very different
when it comes to morals
under the name nolan grayson he's become
a best-selling author that also operates
as a superhero
issue two of the comic runs centers
around his apparent origin story
in which he tells his son mark of the
planet veltrum and we learn of a story
that is likely told to every planet that
the veltromites visit
according to omniman veltrum is a cool
blue oasis planet much like earth
that exists billions of miles away from
our solar system
the population though similar to humans
in appearance
have several abilities that we do not
possess by our standards they
all wield super strength and can move at
super speed
living their highly advanced hashtag
best life has had its benefits
and because of this veltrom has
apparently achieved perfection
omniman or rather nolan tells us that
because of this the planet is somewhat
of a utopia
and there exists no murder or war with
no conflict to tackle
the high council refuse to let their
society become complacent
and they send out their people into the
stars in order to help other planets
develop to their level of perfection
this was a process carried out by the
world betterment committee
which nolan became a part of the mission
was to boldly go where no one had gone
before
and seek out planets at a crucial stage
of development these were ones that had
potential for greatness
rather than ones that were too far along
to the point that their outcome was
decided
according to nolan a team of scientists
would travel to a planet's surface
and help the inhabitants to improve in
every single way
nolan came across earth but this was
deemed too crude to be added to the
betterment schedule
and thus he decided to volunteer to be
earth's soul protector
quickly it became his second home he met
mark's mother debbie
and the pair settled down and had a kid
nolan adopted the moniker of omniman
and apparently became the best of us a
guy that would never
spoil anything that is of course until
he revealed his true mission
which went down worse than joss whedon
at a feminist rally
now nolan revealed that though veltrum
had achieved perfection
this wasn't done through being nice and
the higher-ups of the planet decided
that the weak should be destroyed in
order to obtain intergalactic dominance
after the population of the planet was
halved the council of veltrum decided
that they would bring their new world
order to all those in the galaxy
and in doing so they would create a
galactic empire that would make even
emperor palpatine
realize that sith had hit the fan hey
having that now from here
the world conquering committee travelled
through the universe
finding planets that had the potential
for greatness and were worth conquering
but also ones who hadn't developed their
defenses to the point that they would
pose any threat
and thus the veltromites worked
throughout the universe slowly reshaping
it in their image
they enlisted the forces of the planets
they'd conquered into their ranks
and those that refused were wiped out an
army of slaves was created
and this process went on for millennia
completely uninterrupted
it became civil duty for citizens to
join the committee
and nolan signed up throwing himself
into his work
he crushed and conquered his way through
the universe and quickly
rose through the ranks however veltrum
reached the point where its forces were
stretched too thin
and thus the veltromites devised a new
plan rather than conquering worlds
they would send somewhat of a trojan
horse onto a planet
certain soldiers would be selected to
assimilate with their natives and become
a member of their society
which nolan was hand-picked to do on
earth nolan started to slope into this
society
and during this time he married deborah
whom he viewed as somewhat of a pet
rather than an equal he assumed the
position of earth's protector
and quickly realized that several other
alien species were trying to invade the
planet too
thus he destroyed them so that the
veltromites would face no other
resistance than the humans
and slowly made the earth reliant on his
powers
other heroes rose up including the
guardians of the globe
and no he never became a member he
worked closely alongside
them whilst he raised his son eventually
he realized that they were becoming too
powerful
and made his move in a completely brutal
scene that we see played out in the show
nolan called them together and ambushed
the group completely destroying them one
by one
like i'm gonna do to anyone who thumbs
down this video
i want to see you hitting that thumbs up
like your bloody red rush like your life
depends on it
now this left a vacuum of power on the
world that is sun mark aka invincible
quickly slotted in two nolan expected
his son to join his side in helping him
to invade the planet
but mark resisted and thus the two went
head to head
nolan completely decimated the boy but
just as he was about to kill him
mark said that he will always have a
father and rather than murdering him
where he lay
he flew off into space from this point
onwards
nolan tried to invade other planets in
order to appease the veltromite empire
and he has quite a long arc that we will
no doubt be going over in the series
nolan has a very complicated run in
which he jumps back and forth between
being a hero and villain
but he's just such a fascinating
character to watch i can't wait to see
it play out
now to make things even more complex the
multiverse exists with an invincible
and there are several points in which we
visit a nightmare-esque timeline
when nolan and his son teamed up they
completely ravaged the planet
and the glimpses that we get at these
moments are absolutely terrifying
now as for his powers nolan has very
similar abilities to superman
he is by far the strongest hero on earth
and this has made it so that he can
completely dominate every fight that
he's a part of
a lot of the time he ends up holding
back and even in his battle with the
guardians of the globe
he isn't fighting as hard as he could
nolan can move at super speed
and he too possesses super stamina
beltramites don't build up things like
lactic acid
and thus the character doesn't really
ever get tired or exhausted
all veltromites can fly and also journey
through space without breathing
apparatus which is something that mark
due to being half-human has to have in
general veltromites have huge lung
capacities
and they can hold their breath for up to
two weeks now as shown in mark they are
able to bear children with
other species due to their dominant
genes these often overpower anything
that a human has
and thus all their kids tend to take on
the majority of their powers
one of the most interesting things about
the veltromites is that they actually
age slower the older they get
upon reaching maturity everything about
them slows down
so that their bodies can remain a peak
physical perfection for as long as
possible
this means that it's almost impossible
to know nolan's true age
and due to time dilation in space he
could have existed for what we would
class as millennia on earth
now that they seem perfect they do have
one big weakness the vultromites are
able to fly using the equilibrium in
their ears
but if this is disturbed by a certain
frequency it can cause immense pain
if you manage to find the brown note i'm
not the browner but one of them i'm
guessing
it overwhelms them to the point that
they become incapacitated
and long exposure to this can cause
death either way omniman is a completely
fascinating
character and one of the best spins on
superman that i've ever seen
can't wait to see what they do in the
show and it's going to be great to watch
this classic comic play out on screen
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the character and what you
think will happen in the series comment
below and let me know and as a thank you
for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize during
the 31st of march in which we're giving
away three copies of a marvel 4k box set
of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the character
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of the
first three episodes which will be
linked on screen
right now we've gone over each one of
them from top to bottom so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video i've been poor i'll see you
next time
take care peace